[MUSIC PLAYING]
NAZMUL IDRIS: Hi.
I'm Nazmul Idris, a developer
advocate on the Android team.
And welcome to this
episode of DevBytes.
In today's episode, we're going
to cover the new app indexing
feature that we recently
announced for Google search
for Android.
Currently, when you do a
Google search on the web,
you get results that
are links to websites.
It's not easy to
get your Android
apps by doing web searches.
I mean, you can
find results that
link to listings
on the Play Store,
but you can't do
much more than that.
With App Indexing,
you will now be
able to point Google
search users on Android
directly to content
within your app.
Google search will be
able to surface deep links
within your app directly
in search results
and provide a
call-to-action button
to launch your app directly.
This is particularly useful
when the search terms
are really specific
and can be resolved
to content that's
presented inside
of your Android application.
For example, imagine that you
run a restaurant review website
and have an app that also
shows restaurant reviews.
Thanks to the App Indexing
feature, when a Google
search is done in a mobile
device for a restaurant
and one of your reviews
is a search result,
the user will now be able
to open that result directly
in your application, if
they have it installed.
You also have control
over when Google displays
the open-in-app
call-to-action button
so that you can decide when you
want to guide people to content
on your website
and when you want
to highlight your Android app.
Now, in order to
enable app linking,
you have to perform at least
two things, one on your website,
and one in your
Android application.
On your website, you have
to annotate each page
with app links
that can be opened
in your mobile application.
You need to specify how
the page's content can
be opened in your Android app.
Now, in the Android
app, you have
to add intent filters
for deep linking
in your application
manifest to specify
how to reach specific content
inside of the application.
Correctly configuring
both your website and app
allows Google to
crawl and process
both the website
and app and index
the relationship between the
web page and your app correctly.
This helps our algorithms
show the open-in-app button
in the search results,
if appropriate.
Now, each page on
your site can specify
how its contents can
be loaded in your app.
We offer two equivalent ways
to tell Google's algorithms
about the relationships between
the page and your application.
And these are using
elements
in the  section
of the page's HTML,
or you can use
elements in the sitemap
element specifying the page.
And again, for more details,
please read the blog posts
that will be released.
In order for Google to index
the content in your application
and for users to enter your
application from Google search
results, you must specify intent
filters in your application
manifest that define how
to reach specific content
inside of your application.
And again, for more
details on doing this,
please reference the blog posts.
Now, if you're an
Android developer who
has a web presence and
you want more control
over how your content
is accessed from search
via your website or your
Android application,
App Indexing is a great
feature for you to explore.
Also, enabling your website
and application for indexing
is a great way to
increase engagement
by making your content
more discoverable and more
accessible to users directly
from the search results page.
For more information
on App Indexing,
please visit the
link on the screen
and read the Google Developers
blog post and the Webmaster
blog post as well.
Thanks for joining us
today, and take care.